So what we're really doing here is simply running a scan over the input.
So the input to the scan is a 1 for each 0 bit and a 0 for each 1 bit,
and that will give us the scatter addresses for the 0 half of the split.
So we're going to scatter this element to an output 0, this element to 1,
this element to 2, and this element to 3.
Notice that the last element of the scan,
with a little bit of extra math because it ends with a 0 element here,
tells us how many 0 bits there are total in the input.
In this case there are four--1, 2, 3, 4.
Then we can begin with that value to do a second scan
to compute the scatter addresses for the other half of the split, for the 1 bits.
There are a number of interesting ways to make this faster,
and the most common one is to reduce the total number of passes by taking multiple bits per pass.
Four bits per pass and a resulting 16-way split, instead of our 2-way split here,
appears to be fairly common.
Overall, radix sort is a fairly brute force algorithm, but it's both simple and fast.
Recent GPUs can run radix sort on 32-bit keys at a rate of over a billion keys sorted per second.